so 1990 1991
you are curious at this point on what's
going on and you start investigating
you went all the way down from the
bankers all the way to the top of the
you know
the bank of japan and you kind of
realized fukui what's going on great
so
in 86 if you can for 30 seconds if you
can just kind of give us some
perspective from 86 to 89 how much was
value of real estate going up and what
kind of money were these guys making
just for us to kind of get a
visualization
well property prices were rising by
several hundred percent
per year
uh in in um well in total so in this in
this three year three four years you
mean to tell me like a half a million
dollar property could end up being a two
million dollar property oh yeah of
course you're serious yes yeah yeah yeah
and okay so and this is happening in
specifically three years
maybe four if you yeah
at half a year on both ends so so then
then
how similar were interest rates like you
know how we dropped the rates down to
zero and we had 128 month economic
expansion oh my gosh what a great time
it was and then
you know what were they doing with
interest rates what did inflation look
like what did gas prices look like what
did unemployment look like was it like a
1.2 unemployment interest rates were
really low what what were the conditions
there
unemployment has always been low in
japan
that started to rise only from the
second half of the 1990s when the
recession started to get bad
and then in the 2000s you know we had we
hit
peak unemployment which but by
international standards is still low but
by japanese standards was the highest
ever
in earlier in the post-war era yes
um inflation
in the 80s was very low as well
um because most money creation um was
going into asset prices and well so the
normal measure of inflation is consumer
prices consumer prices stayed fairly
uh constant fairly flat in fact there
was some deflation because the yen was
rising import prices were going down and
um
so you didn't see what was happening
and then that's actually the reason why
as japan if if we quickly uh moved to to
capital flows briefly japan was creating
all this money
uh via the asset markets
uh inflating asset prices and some of
that spilled over as capital outflows
that explains this flood of money and i
solved that puzzle you know this flood
of money from japan was this bankrupt
creation in asset markets now normally
you'd see that
and you say well they're just printing
money and they're buying foreign assets
the yen should go down but it's not a
it's not an automatic mechanism you know
market players have to understand this
and realize oh they're just printing the
money uh that's why we're gonna sell the
yen and they start to sell the yen but
this didn't happen they saw oh consumer
price inflation zero or negative well
the yen they're obviously not printing
money and the yen should be strong and
it stays strong while they went around
the world buying up assets everywhere
um now you mentioned interest rates of
course that's it's an interesting
question always because any central bank
watcher um
i mean in the mainstream will focus on
interest rates and central banks
themselves will always
try to get your attention
focused on interest rates
and it's a bit like the magician on
stage when they're performing a trick
and of course they don't want you to see
what really does the trick when they do
that hand movement they will distract
your attention with the other hand and
say look here this is happening maybe
have a little diversion story
and that's what interest rates are
but it's such a huge diversion it's it's
worthwhile spending a few uh moments on
this because actually famously there's
so many different schools in economics
right different schools of thought
different economies they all have
different ideas they always argue and
squabble well
there's one
idea that all the different schools of
economic thought of the last 200 years
in english language economics
agree on
namely they all say if you lower rates
this is good for the economy growth will
go up if you raise interest rates this
will slow the economy
you can go back to david ricardo
classical economist alfred marshall
neoclassical economics
keynes um certainly said that
monetarists
said that um
[Music]
you know all sorts of neoclass new
classical economics um
neo-vixilin all the schools of thought
agree on this point and central bankers
for the last 30 years have been saying
this on a daily basis watch interest
rates because when we raise them it's
going to slow things if we lower them
it's going to stimulate
they say this constantly now
because this is repeated so many times
we all assume
quite reasonably that of course this has
been empirically tested and checked
hundreds of times maybe thousands of
times so we don't need to check this
right
well how many empirical studies exist
that demonstrate this relationship
five
zero wow there isn't one because
i did the first empirical check of this
it's very hard to publish this nobody
you know the economist don't want you to
see this but
um
what i found is it's not true
it's it's just not true there is no
empirical evidence for this
so the official so what we're doing
today in the states when we're
increasing rates to prevent from
inflation taking place
that makes zero sense to do it's not
going to help it it's not going to help
if the real cause of inflation which is
not interest rate is still in place and
that is money creation for
unproductive purposes for consumption if
they keep doing that and you can do that
at higher rates you can still push out
the
the credit creation in the banking
system you will get accelerating
inflation and in fact then you'll find
that the higher interest rates make
certain things more expensive mortgages
and whatever rents will start to move up
you know it's not gonna end inflation if
the credit creation continues so i did i
but i wanted to show this because you
can always have scenarios where maybe
you know you think it could work or not
so it's an empirical question
and i did the first empirical test using
data on the us the uk germany and japan
for half a century
and it was open-ended my my question was
simply what actually does the data tell
us is the relationship between interest
rates and we tried together with a
colleague um
[Music]
econometrician
and we um we asked well
looking at three different types of
interest rates short rates um long-term
10-year government bond yields and so on
what is the relation between interest
rates and economic growth
the official story is is a negative
correlation lower rates higher growth
higher rates lower so negative inverse
relationship and causation supposed to
be from interest rates to growth there's
supposed to be some causation there what
we found
was
diametrically opposed to this on both in
both dimensions
the correlation
is actually positive
so higher rates and higher growth always
go hand in hand lower rates and lower
growth always go hand in hand and the
causation statistical causation that you
can test for
runs from growth to interest rates
interest rates follow growth and
therefore they can't be the cause
and that tells you that can't be the the
best monarchy policy tool at all
that paper is published you can also
look it up that's called
re it's also open source reconsidering
monetary policy
um the only journal that will publish
this fairly good journal still but um
was ecological economics it's in there
peer-reviewed journal
an empirical examination of the relation
between interest rates and gdp growth
we've got another paper coming out now
which looks at real growth industrial
production for 19 countries it's the
same conclusion so reality is interest
rates work differently and they're not
really the cause of what's happening so
but central banks love to talk about it
because that way they distract your
attention you focus on something that's
not key and they can then use that to to
make sure you don't really understand so
what they're doing so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]